and now we're gonna get to the news amid tensions
over possible military action in ukraine president
biden will meet on a video call tomorrow with
russian president vladimir putin because there's
no better deterrent than a long video call with
a 79 year old man you know this is not worth it
cnn announced over the weekend that it has
terminated host chris cuomo and if you're
wondering what you have to do to get fired
from cnn jeffrey tubin still works there
and if you don't know it i don't google it
the binding administration announced today
that the u.s will stage a diplomatic boycott
of the 2022 beijing olympics and in retaliation
china announced that the iphone
14 is going to look like this
arizona senator kirsten cinema announced in an
instagram story over the weekend that she had
officially qualified for the upcoming boston
marathon but fair warning to the other runners
she loves holding things up at the finish line in
a recent interview actor george clooney said that
he turned down 35 million dollars to appear
in an airline commercial because the carrier
was associated with a country that does not
have a good human rights record is it a american
new york mayor bill de blasio announced
today that all private employers in the
city will soon be required to mandate
coronavirus vaccinations for workers
otherwise it's back to remote
work for times square elmo
i don't i don't think times square
elmo has a plan in his office
i don't think that's real shoemaker
the new york times published a report yesterday
detailing a series of coronavirus infections
stemming from an anime convention held last
month in new york well something tells me
they'll be fine with quarantining oh you want
me to stay inside for 10 days not a problem
according to the latest numbers the average cost
per day for a rental car during the holiday season
is up by 75 percent compared to 2019. even worse
they consider this a chevy malibu or similar
and finally a man in italy reportedly
wore a fake silicone arm last week to
avoid getting the coronavirus vaccine and wait
till you hear how he got out of his vasectomy
president biden held a virtual meeting
today with russian president vladimir
putin though it was weird that they
decided to do it in the metaverse
according to a new book hours after former
president trump announced in 2020 that he had
tested positive for the coronavirus his health
deteriorated very quickly they kept him alive
by immediately hooking him up
to a camera in a microphone
set a majority leader that's my oxygen
senate majority leader chuck schumer
yesterday reiterated his goal
for democrats to pass the build back better
spending bill by christmas the same night
joe manchin will be visited by three spirits
new york governor kathy hokel announced yesterday
that there are a total of 12 confirmed cases
of the omicron variant of the coronavirus
across the state that story again there are
12 000 cases of the omicron variant in new york
state we got 12. we're sure that's it the fifth
annual gingerbread replica of the capitol made its
debut yesterday but sadly it's just been breached
you know what he's so lovable
you're still rooting for him
during a new interview billionaire elon
musk said that his neurolink company hopes
to start implanting brain chips in humans
sometimes next year kind of intriguing but
i don't think i'd get the first one i mean
you remember the iphone one exactly you know
you get the first chip and in three years everyone
will be like making fun of you you got the one
can you even watch tick tocks with
that today was maine senator susan
collins 69th birthday though she's
confident that she will remain 68.
they all left
trump tower recently began
selling a cocktail inspired
by former president trump called 45 and
it secretly reports to a white russian
okay
it really hammers home how the last joke did
maybe it's them oh it's not
than 30 people recently spent the night at an ikea
in denmark after a snowstorm stranded them at the
store and then they were stranded another
night because they couldn't find the exit
and i didn't know this but in denmark
all their furniture has normal names
it was announced today that investment
manager peter lynch will donate more than
20 million dollars worth of art to his
alma mater boston college's art museum
lynch hopes the donation will help bostonians
learn to correctly pronounce the word art
now that's hot that's out bro
and finally instagram today launched
a so-called take a break tool
a break from instagram or as
it's otherwise called twitter
the white house is reportedly lobbying news
organizations to give president biden more
favorable press coverage or as cnn reported
it desperate biden begs for compliments
ahead of president biden's first ever summit of
global democracies this week chinese officials
questioned how a country like the us
could lecture other nations given its
polarized domestic politics and botched
coronavirus response man it sucks when
someone you don't like makes a good point
it's like o.j telling kids to get vaccinated
he's not wrong you just don't love agreeing with
him listen to jews kids no i'm not that part
during his trip today to kansas city missouri
president biden unveiled new branding
for his build back better plan cool maybe you can
change the name so it doesn't sound like
a chiropractor's office in a strip mall
during a recent panel discussion west virginia
senator joe manchin referred to democrats using
the third person they even worse he referred
to coal lobbyists as we that's right democratic
senator joe manchin referred to democrats using
the third person they not cool but i do the same
thing with my family when i'm home for the
holidays they want to go to applebee's again
a boater in florida recently discovered a
package in the ocean that was filled with
one million dollars worth of cocaine damn
no wonder he's always in such a good mood
i mean come on you don't have the idea to live
in a pineapple without doing some coke first
tampa bay buccaneers quarterback
tom brady announced plans this week
for a new collection of nfts
that will include a stopwatch
cleats the jersey he wore at the nfl
combine and even his very first helmet
and finally the makers of oreos have announced a
partnership with the wine brand barefoot to offer
an oreo thins red blend wine which complements
the chocolate and cream of the cookies so
if you're craving oreos and red wine don't
worry you're gonna get through this breakup
after meeting with russian president vladimir
putin on tuesday president biden said yesterday
that he was quote straightforward but polite
with putin and putin was as warm as ever oh
during a radio interview yesterday
former president trump referred to
president biden's build back better
plan as quote build back worse in
case you were wondering what he's
been working on these past 11 months
oh but i think i got it mel
president biden spoke today with
ukrainian president voldemir
zelensky amid a russian military
buildup on the ukraine border
and informed him that while he cannot
send troops he will send a little support
in his new book ex-white house chief of staff
mark meadows writes that former president
trump was mortified after the capital attack and
worried about his media coverage was he mortified
donald trump that guy can't be embarrassed he
wasn't embarrassed after this or or after this
or even after this this is the same
guy who thought tim cook's name
was tim apple because he worked for apple if you
don't step down after that you're just not someone
who gets embarrassed actually you know what i
haven't seen that in a minute can we throw it
up i mean you've really put a big investment in
our country we appreciate it very much tim apple
a las vegas money manager is reportedly proposing
plans to build a casino in new york city
or if you really want to gamble in
new york city touch a subway poll
the head of instagram testified yesterday before
congress but only after an hour of explaining what
it was to chuck grassley yeah do you have
to have one of them cordless phones for it
the makers of miller lite recently
began offering drinkable christmas
ornaments oh they're drinkable
what's inside them heineken
and finally and finally google
released its annual so-called
year in search list yesterday and the second
most searched how to be phrase was how to
be more attractive whereas the third most
searched was how to be happy alone and it's
kind of fun to see people give up in real time
and how to be more attractive a lot of steps
that was a monologue everybody oh man
you